i'm christopher hine and we're going to
make some more videos for you guys about
conrad wazza
so we have a three-part series here on
udeo se
the the this the breakdown of this is a
little different than the first video i
made because the first video i kind of
had to explain what conrad waza was as
we went
and now i'm assuming you've seen that
video if you haven't you should watch
the first video on conor nawaza which is
on the patreon page and you can see it
no problem it's also on youtube you can
see it
but we're going to talk here about the
extension
of the udeoce which comes off of that
ikyo and
ureose just means the arm pinning
technique or arm controlling technique
so from that we're going to see what the
takedown's about what the conron for the
takedown is and that's going to be this
video we're also going to then follow up
with a video on
what to do if you cannot get the take
down and then what to do if they can
absolutely overcome you so we're going
to make those three in the series this
first one right now that you're watching
is going to be about the takedown itself
i'm going to get josh we're going to go
to work josh
all right so we're going to talk about
udeo se uh in this portion we're going
to talk about udesay
just for the takedown so what are the
adaptations for the uro
and the takedown when we're talking
about conor nawaz a lot of the stuff i'm
going to show you you've already learned
in
aikido forms you probably just don't
recognize it as
answers to upcoming problems once you
understand the whole the syllabus you
can kind of go back and look through it
you can see that
the forum teaches you conrad rather
naturally and
you don't need to go through and learn a
set of conrent
but the problem with that is you don't
as clearly get it as you will in just
studying a set of conjurings so we're
going to talk about the conjuring for
udeo
all right so udeo say just means arm pin
we're going to start right from this
position
now you could call this the ikkyo pin if
you want
um or ikiose but that's only one
aspect of all the stuff that comes from
this series
alright now if you happen to have
someone in this position
and you want to make the takedown how
does the takedown go through
now you should start with this with the
lead leg being on the outside
and the near leg the leg that's near him
being on the inside and the reason for
that is
this makes it most difficult for him to
get a hold of my leg so if i had his arm
here decently if he goes to get my legs
you can see that leg's going to cost him
right he's going to fall down for
that leg if he reaches over for this
other leg it's real hard for him to get
and going to cost him okay
however if i have this leg forward he
really easily can sneak in and grab that
leg and that's going to give me trouble
so before i have this guy in a decent
control position
i want to make sure my near leg is back
and my my outside leg is the far forward
leg
okay now when i want to get this guy
down what am i trying to do
when he's like he is right now so that
other hand's not touching that means
he's balanced and can balance on his
feet
i do not want to step in until i take
that balance away
so i need to in some way get him nudged
forward to do that now the second he
touches
he needs three points to be balanced so
in this three point balance
i can step forward because if you were
to grab my leg here he's got no balance
and he'll fall down right so
that's the time when you can safely step
in is once this hand touches
until that hand touches you can't risk
stepping in because
most likely he's gonna he's gonna be
able to get you now understand
all this is coming off of our aikido
context i'm not going to hit that in
this video right now because
it'll take too long to talk about but
this came up because of an
inherent imbalance in whatever he was
doing and that's why this came up
and for some reason pinning him was a
good option and there's tons of reasons
that could be
there's a situation i need to control
he's armed i need to save
other people all kinds of other stuff
talk about that in other videos but
this is coming off of the aikido context
so i want the outside leg forward
near leg is back until he touches once
he touches i can safely step in
now this stepping in is going to feel
better to you because now i have more
weight over the top of him
so it's going to be easier for me to
control this guy now how do i get him
down
if i'm lucky when i take my initial step
in
i will bump him off balance and he'll
pretty much get broken down at that
point right so that would be really
fantastic
if my initial step is what hit him so
once he
he touches there and i step this leg in
my goal is to try and knock him straight
back like that
and if i can break him down there then
good and i'll just work him the rest of
the way down
i'll drop the inside leg here and then
i'll go into the pin from here
if after i've got him to touch i step in
and he just adjusts by sticking his hand
out then i'm going to pull him this way
like this
okay and he'll shoot his hand i'll step
in and and let me explain what's going
to go on this process all right and
josh is doing a lot of work here he has
to stay in this position so
once his hand touches that's what's
helping him balance over there
he's got nothing balancing over here so
if he's shot his hand out so far that i
didn't break his balance there
there's a possibility to pull him into
this gap here
to break him down right there and that's
what i'd like to have is have that
little gap happen
but he can also shoot his hand out here
to stop that from happening
but now he's not balanced over there so
i'll drive into that right
so what i'm trying to do when i when i'm
trying to get the take down from here
is move back and forth like this so he
only has one hand to balance himself
and eventually i should be able to break
him down by going back and forth back
and forth back and forth like that
okay now as i'm doing this there's
several things i can do with the arm
okay
white right now the way that you're
seeing me do this is a really poor rokyo
so it's against the joint here it's a
bad roku
i would prefer to get the eq if i could
right so this ikea what it does if you
watch josh's balance so watch if i go
from here
watch me rotate this elbow i'm already
putting him into a worse position so if
i can stay on the underside of the elbow
it's going to be a lot easier to control
him for the takedown than it is if i
can't
now he might not like that so he very
well might straighten that elbow out
and keep me from doing that you're going
to experience this a lot with your ukes
where they're going to try and
straighten their arm out to keep you
from doing that
now you have a few options one of the
options is to go right into the roku
here with your hand where i press
in here and i'm trying to get this
control another option is to use the
straight arm he's giving you to go into
the shoulder so i can go into the
shoulder and i'm driving right into the
shoulder joint with that
you can also readjust this hand to go
into
a number of different things one is
gokyo one is nico we can get sankyo so
we can go into a few different things
here but i can use the control at the
wrist here to try and get him to go
where i want
so ideally when i'm working this
breakdown here i would like to have this
elbow rolled
but if i can't hold that and he
straightens it out i can drive into the
elbow itself i can drive
into the shoulder or i can control this
hand and go into the hand
and i can use all those things to help
me start breaking his balance because
while that's going on i'm
going back and forth back and forth back
and forth trying to break his balance
down
let josh stand up here for a sec okay so
that's the objective i've driven into
him and i'm controlling his arm
i want to keep my near leg back until
he's touching once he touches i know
that he's not stable on just the two
legs so that means it's safe to step in
when i step in i want to step in
dominantly and ideally i'll just
knock him down when i do that if i don't
do that i'm going to immediately pull
him back
to this area right here where he doesn't
have a hand so what he'll probably try
to do is shoot his hand over there to
keep himself from falling
and then i'll drive over here so
basically what's happening is i'm always
pulling where his hand isn't so if his
hand was here i'm gonna pull him this
way when i pull him this way he'll move
his hand over here to stop himself from
falling that way
then i immediately push back here if he
moves his hand back here then i pull
back so
back and forth i'm going back and forth
back and forth back and forth to break
him down
if i need a little more encouragement
i'm i'm going to try to use the echo
because eco is going to give me a really
nice advantage as long as i can hold it
if i can't get the eq i could go into
the rokyo with my hand i can go into his
shoulder directly
and i can go into a gokyo or enikyo over
here to help get him down right
so those are my main ideas once i'm in
that udeo say position and i'm trying to
get the take down
now if i can't get the takedown what do
i do
our next video series we're going to
talk about if you cannot possibly manage
the takedown
i'm christopher hine thanks for watching